welcome to the Microsoft translator hub
in this video you'll learn how to deploy
a translation system and solicit
feedback from the community after a set
of trainings has been conducted go to
the project details page and select a
training with a good blue score the blue
score is a metric that you can use to
compare different training runs and
decide on which data and settings
produce a better result you may want to
consult with project reviewers before
deciding that the quality is sufficient
for deployment in the training results
page of the selected training you'll see
the option to deploy translator system
click on that deploy translator system
to submit a request to deploy a training
run an email will be sent to Microsoft
with the details of the training and
information required to process the
deployment please allow several business
days for the deployment request to be
processed you will receive an email
confirming the availability of your
translator system as soon as the
deployment has taken place after a
translator system has been deployed you
can use the test translation page to
access the translator system and use it
to provide translations to verify the
quality of a translator system go to the
test translator link under the community
menu enter the test sentence into the
left box and then click translate the
translation of the source sentence or
sentences will be displayed in the two
box here on the right after you've
tested the deployed translator system
you can then begin sharing documents
that have been translated by your
translator system and solicit feedback
from your community go to the community
pulldown menu and select invite reviews
select the documents you wish to share
and click the share button these
documents will then become visible to
members in both the reviewer and
co-owner roles you can also share the
document with people who are not in
either of these assigned roles to allow
someone who is not an assigned member to
review documents go to the shared
document tab and select the documents
that you want to have reviewed and then
click on the email icon enter their
email address or addresses and then
click the send button
let's look at the process of reviewing
documents and submitting alternate
translations a person in the role of
reviewer and co-owner can log-in with a
live ID and then click the reviewers
dashboard under projects in the section
titled projects with documents shared
for review click the name of the project
this will open the review documents page
listing all of the shared documents
click the name of the document to open
the review document page a person
invited by email will be able to open
the review document page directly by
clicking on the link within the email
the source language will be on the left
and the target will be on the right
mouse over the translation you wish to
update and then click improve
translation type in your suggested
changes and then click the submit button
now we'll jump back to the process as a
project owner only project owners and
co-owners can review and approve
alternate translations provided by
reviewers as a project owner go to
invite reviews under the community menu
select the model you wish to review from
the drop-down list and then click manage
translations you'll see each translation
that has been submitted by a reviewer
and then be able to take one of three
courses of action if the translation is
appropriate and correct select approve
if the translation is not appropriate or
incorrect select reject if you wish to
further edit the translation select edit
you will have to repeat this process for
each sentence translation once you've
received sufficient feedback from your
reviewers you can decide to retrain your
translator system based on reviewer
inputs or additional data you may have
uploaded to do this go back to the
project details page and start a new
training you can either use the add
trading option to start from scratch
or select the previous training run and
use the clone training option to
download the set of suggested
alternative translations submitted by
the reviewers in the setup training page
click download community translations
this will bring up a
log showing the count of community
submitted translations click download to
download a zip file containing these
translations after you have reviewed the
downloaded sentence files you can upload
them back to the setup training page
using the add documents link for
additional information check out our
other videos in the Help section as well
as the in-depth documentation on the
site